in the documentary they talk about
dolphin me because it's it's such a big
fish the meat is so full of mercury
right it's oh yeah it's actually a
mammal but because it's such a big
animal it's meat is full of toxic levels
of mercury so it's not even good for you
to eat right after that some of the
experts and what I've learned is kind of
you don't really want to eat fish that
are bigger than your plate the bigger
the fish is the more the higher it is on
the food chain the higher in the food
chain it's eating things that are eating
other things that are eating other
things and so the levels of toxicity
build up and then when you have dolphins
that can live 20 30 40 years and they're
big the levels build up immensely and
then when you have whales it's even more
so and you know with the dolphin meat we
were finding levels that were two
thousand times the legal limit and so an
Taiji also has a mortality rate 50%
higher than any village of its size so
there's something going on in Taiji like
clearly and it's not in any other city
and it mercury poisoning is not
something that like you wake up one day
like I'm sick like it's degenerative so
what happens is it's like changing the
neurons in your brain and it's changing
who you are as a person slowly so you
don't notice the changes but you're
slowly becoming this other person and
like your hearing goes out and you're
yelling and like things like that
happened that you don't really notice
and so it's hard you know they haven't
really done the testing that they need
to do their because clearly something's
going on and didn't at one point
somebody say to the people of ties you
to the fishermen in particular let hey
we'll give you will pay you all the
money that you're making slaughtering
these dolphins if you'll just consider
stop this killing and stopping the
fishing of these dolphins and they
refused it because they said it was a
part of their their culture that they
didn't want to give up or it was up what
you hit him with they come with some
other reason so it's like you know it's
not about you know it's it's I've heard
the reason it's pest control right there
are no more fish in the ocean because
the dolphins ate them all like they put
up sharks before where they're like
literally saying the Dolphins of whales
are eating all the fish therefore are
fishing it's clearly the overfishing
that's causing there's no fish not well
well so they say it's pest control they
say you know they're dolphins and fish
there's no difference between the two so
what's the big deal you know you guys
eat pigs and chickens and cows and there
is every reason so so anyway you know
but what happens with the mercury issue
and so we hammer on it for us if we
would we're there we try to portray this
not as it's not an animal rights issue
we're not like oh they're dull cute
dolphins you need to save them we were
like they're full of toxic mercury these
people are eating him when we first got
there eating dolphin meat was compulsory
in the school systems like it's no
longer like that anymore but they were
forcing the kids to eat dolphin meat
because they were trying to make them
dolphin eat so there'd be a pipeline
that when they get older they'll still
buy dolphin meat so they could justify
it they can justify it and also create a
future generation of people that will
buy this product you know in Japan like
everyone's family eight will meet after
World War two they were dependent and
anything they could eat and you know
historically they are a whaling nation
and if you go to Japan it's very
mountainous they have in trouble that's
why I like all cattle all beef from
japan is exported for imported from
Australia you can't really there's no
place in Japan to grow cattle so they're
dependent on the outside world for their
food they're an island and they're the I
think fourth largest economy in the
world yet they're for their food they're
completely dependent on the outside
world and so they're very cautious if
like one cow gets mad cow disease it's
like they stopped all imports into Japan
they shut it down st. Byrne flew the
same thing they're dependent on China
for poultry but the reality is in Japan
like 90 percent of people eat some sort
of seafood
percent of the time they eat everything
and jellyfish fish I mean when you get
breakfast there you'll get 10 different
bowls the open one there's eyeballs and
I mean just all sorts of stuff going on
that's just that culture there and so if
it turned out that the seafood is not
safe to eat and there's mercury that
country is in real trouble they've now
got a food crisis going on there because
now they're completely depend on the
outside world for food they can't
sustain themselves and so that's why the
government there is so careful about how
to approach this murk because there's
definitely saw a problem going on in
Taiji we're testing the meat all the
meat is toxic people are eating that
meat there's no warning labels on it
pregnant loner eating it old people are
eating it but I think the second the
government admits there's a problem it
opens up liability that these people can
now sue the government everybody could
sue the government in Japan potentially
so it's a Pandora's box that we've
started with this mercury issue they're
not like glass that can have their own
cows and they could just cut themselves
off in the world and do their own thing
like they're dependent on the rest of
the world for food if especially if
their seafood is not safe which is what
they eat for breakfast lunch and dinner
aren't they also one of the biggest
seafood exporters probably and and it's
not necessarily caught there for
instance like tuna like the tuna you buy
your store or you go to a sushi
restaurant there's tuna there that tuna
might have been in caught in Argentina
two weeks before and then it was shipped
to Japan where it goes through the tuna
auction and then from that through Knox
and it was shipped to a seller a buyer
in the States so it's you know even
though Japan may have not caught that to
know a lot of the fish goes through to
Japan before it goes anywhere in the
world that's where they have the big
seafood auctions interesting they
control those markets